prenez pas le Savary bonjour monsieur
Savary vous êtes un peu le chef de fil
DLR sur cette réforme vous êtes le
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse du
projet de loi de financement de sécurité
sociale la sécurité sociale mais
effectivement quand on le dit avec plus
de simplicité c'est encore mieux pour
noter les spectateurs mais qu'est-ce que
vous vous dites vous quand vous voyez
ces 3000 626 amendements qu'il reste à
examiner et ce rythme assez lent parce
qu'il y a des amendements mais aussi des
explications de vote venus de la gauche
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque bah écoutez
sur les amendements qui rentrent dans le
texte c'est tout à fait intéressant sauf
que jusqu'à présent nous n'avons vu que
des amendements de suppression alors une
fois qu'on s'est exprimé sur la
suppression il y en a des dizaines et
des dizaines et des dizaines qui sont
tout à fait similaires c'est la raison
pour laquelle le texte effectivement on
n'avance pas c'est assez assez
surprenant je dirais comme comme
technique
parlementaire puisque à la fois on nous
demande des explications sur la prise en
compte de la pénibilité comment on pense
accélérer par exemple les les la
convergence des régimes spéciaux tout
cela sont c'est dans des articles plus
loin donc c'est un patient ce ce traduit
et c'est contradictoires par nombre
d'affrontements de suppressions de
l'article donc il rapporte dans tout ça
quoi on avait parlé hier d'obstruction
courtoises de la part de la gauche
c'est-à-dire énormément de prise de
parole mais tout ça sur un ton très
feutré la gauche elle vous accuse vous
aussi de faire l'obstruction par votre
silence vous les LR qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez ben écoutez les je pense
que tous les Sénats de 10 sénateurs qui
sont exprimés depuis ce matin absolument
parce que tous les sénateurs qu'ils
soient de la majorité sénatoriale ou de
l'opposition sont impatients de traiter
ces problèmes de régime spéciaux ou
d'âge où toutes les mesures de justice
sociale que l'on peut proposer les uns
en faisant des amendements et des
amendements
vous pouvez en dire très les autres bah
ils attendent tranquillement qu'on
aborde les vrais sujets et là crois-moi
croyez-moi vous vous les entendre
qu'est-ce que ça dit aussi dans l'émo
chauve-souris mais est-ce que on peut
aller vers la fin de l'examen d'un texte
en 11 jours il en reste maintenant 10
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
faisable selon vous avec votre
expérience sur ces projets de la
financement de la sécurité sociale ça
devient plus le temps passe moins c'est
faisable d'accord et donc s'il y a une
volonté d'aller jusqu'au bout du texte
et bien il faut la montrer nous nous la
monterons puisque nous ne parlons pas
sur des amendements tous identiques mais
par contre il me semble que les
sénateurs de l'opposition s'ils veulent
véritablement aller jusqu'au bout du
texte doivent traduire leur intention
peut-être en supprimant les amendements
identiques simplement parce que le droit
d'amendement nous le respectons bien
largement bien sûr allons sur le fond de
cet article 1 qui est au cœur des
discussions depuis ce matin ils vise à
supprimer cinq régimes spéciaux on dit
fermer des régimes et vous allez nous
expliquer cette distinction mais
justement on voit ces régimes spéciaux
la RATP l'éclair de notaire etc c'est
quelque chose que vous soutenez dans la
version du gouvernement et d'ailleurs
que vous soutenez dans cette version il
n'a pas besoin d'aller plus loin c'est
ça non non
ça mérite précision effectivement ça
fait 4 ans que la majorité sénatoriale
propose voilà propose un projet de
réforme du système de retraite à la fois
avec les bornes d'âge mais également ça
a toujours été sur tous les amendements
une convergence des régimes spéciaux que
propose l'article 1 de fermer ces
régimes spéciaux au nouveau entrants ça
veut dire que ces régimes spéciaux
effectivement seront en voie
d'extinction
beaucoup plus que ça le temps d'avoir
réglé tous ceux qui sont des cotisants
et qui bénéficieront d'une retraite ça
veut dire le temps de la carrière plus
le temps de la retraite plus le temps de
la reversion donc dans 60 à 80 ans que
seront effectivement éteint les régimes
spéciaux donc il y a une marge de temps
tout à fait significatif
pour qu'on comprenne bien certains
élèves mais donc pas au nom de la
commission mais au nom du groupe
politique LR vont souhaiter aller plus
loin c'est ça et pas forcément lors de
l'examen de l'article 1 mais plus tard
sur l'article 7 que l'on connaît pour
cette mesure d'âge c'est bien ça oui
tout à fait l'article 1 c'est la
fermeture de ces régimes voilà on parle
pas des régimes quand on parle des
régimes et des décalages éventuels d'âge
c'est l'article 7 comme on décale l'âge
de 62 à 64 ans vous voyez c'est le même
article parce que après il faut décliner
le décalage selon les différents régimes
puisqu'ils ont déjà anticipé donc on
verra ce débat revenir plus tard dans la
semaine prochaine lorsqu'on sera sur
l'article 7 et c'est là qu'on aura des
amendements DLR pour aller plus loin
voilà les amendements porteront
effectivement sur les décalages d'âge à
savoir si on attend 70 ans ou dans un
délai 10 à 15 ans
on fait en sorte que une égalité de
traitement dans toutes les personnes
dans un intérêt dans ces régimes
spéciaux
[Musique]